[Applause]
it's nice to meet you nice to meet you
you are incredibly talented oh thank you
like this film people are gonna freak
out i'm just saying you're incredibly
gifted so you're playing like such an
icon elvis were you musical as a kid i
my dad gave me a guitar when i was 13
years old and yeah i obsessed about it i
would play for eight hours a day my
fingers would bleed and i'd super
yeah cool but i never played for anybody
i i it was like therapy you know oh you
were shy about it
oh my gosh you were shy and you ended up
getting elvis yeah it's kind of that's
ironic bizarre yeah did you play
anything else did you yeah i played the
piano as well i picked that up about a
year after that oh wow and that opened
up you know how
you learn a lot about music playing the
piano so yeah yeah it opened up a lot i
love that and it's like even if you
didn't become like a musician in a band
it's like it's an amazing thing i think
even my kids i'm like you know what to
be in a band but i want you to play
something i think it's good for you i
think it's therapeutic do they play in
[ __ ]
my daughter plays violin a little bit my
son is six he hasn't started yet yeah
violin was the first thing i learned how
to play me too yeah yeah it was violin
and then piano were you shooting guitar
as a kid
yes until music okay interesting
yeah nobody believes me but i was shy at
some point in my life my mom will tell
you and i was very like um i don't know
just like introverted and and then music
like brought me
to life like my personality and
everything i think any time when you're
a kid i don't know if you agree
you find that one thing that really like
helps you flourish and find your
personality and find out who you are
yeah that was acting for me but you
started acting kind of in a weird way
right was it your brother yeah yeah i
had a stepbrother and he got scouted at
the orange county fair
and so and we all thought oh he's going
to be a movie star now's the now i mean
he's going to go off and do all these
things and so i just tagged along as he
went up to this audition in los angeles
yeah and when they saw that my mom had
another kid they were like he you does
he want to do it too my mom said are you
interested and
well i don't know what came over me that
day because i was so shy
but i said yeah and then uh and then
that got me into it it turned out it was
a background talent agent yeah so he got
you into doing extra work on nickelodeon
shows yeah
and that's that's what got me into
that's the door yeah and then i got my
first manager and and started going to
acting class and acting class broke me
out of my shyness in a way yeah that
gave me an outlet for it you know did
they make you just do the most awkward
things yeah always okay i've never done
it i kind of want to do it just for fun
just to force myself to hate my life a
little bit and like you know you're
supposed to do things that you don't
think you'd be good at like to like grow
or whatever yeah so yeah it feels like
it would terrify me
[Music]